[Music]
foreign
and I'm a lecturer in accounting at the
Stanford Graduate School of Business I'd
love to share some key takeaways from
the class I teach analysis and
measurement of impact which is part of
the action learning program
so what is impact investing
it refers to Investments made according
to three criteria
intentional social or environmental
benefit
positive Financial returns and an effort
to measure impact
ESG is a framework for helping
stakeholders understand how an
organization manages risks and
opportunities around sustainability
issues so ESG tends to be based on
backward looking measures resulting from
the normal course of business or
activity that has already occurred
impact investing on the other hand is
forward-looking it's a strategy used to
define the types of investment an
investor is targeting against goals it
seeks to achieve because investors opt
in to impact funds knowing the
investment manager's intentions before
investing it is subject to far less
fiduciary scrutiny than ESG
foreign
intentionality or a deliberate desire to
contribute to measurable social or
environmental change is a core
characteristic of impact investing and
it's what differentiates it from other
investing approaches
developing a thoughtful and well-defined
investment in Impact thesis goes a long
way toward communicating your intended
impact
the heart of impact investing seeks to
address some of the biggest issues
affecting the planet and Humanity impact
Market participants understand the
urgency of addressing these issues and
they're well beyond the point of
discussing the reasons for Action
they're about taking action whether from
a financial political or business
standpoint
in addition the industry is critical of
efforts to sell the story for impact
washing purposes
because of this authenticity is a core
value in the impact space meaning that
what you say and what you do are in
alignment
those who do not adhere to these
characteristics are likely to get called
out in a space that is highly
collaborative and unapologetically bold
over the last decade efforts to coalesce
around a consistent set of impact
measurement and monitoring Frameworks
has increased greatly
however the field continues to evolve
and there exists no consensus on the
best way to measure impact instead
different organizations may take
drastically different approaches
depending on their position along the
impact Spectrum or the asset being
measured and qualitative results can be
just as important as quantitative
metrics
for example a multi-billion dollar
climate fund may take a highly
quantitative evidence-based approach to
measuring impact and a smaller fund
focused on addressing the needs of
marginalized communities may prefer a
low-cost and highly insightful approach
through qualitative surveys of
individuals directly impacted by their
Investments
there's no one-size-fits-all or copy and
paste approach to measuring impact
instead it's as much of an art as it is
a science
impact measurement can be messy but
measuring something is better than
nothing and it's important to regularly
analyze your impact measurement process
for patterns or formulas that can lead
to bias or blind spots
foreign
[Music]
characteristics of impact investing is a
positive Financial return and
importantly this is what distinguishes
it from philanthropy still the impact
Spectrum varies greatly with many
Pathways to impact a below market rate
investment for example may appear to
sacrifice returns for impact relative to
a market rate or above market rate
investment but collinearity of returns
and impact is the goal of all Impact
investors
in other words impact investing need not
be concessionary if the focus is on
maximizing both returns and impact in an
interconnected and mutually reinforcing
way
this can be accomplished with a rigorous
approach to impact investment analysis
and measurement
[Music]
s unlike traditional investing impact
due diligence goes beyond the point of
investment
impact investors continue to Monitor and
measure key impact metrics to the point
of exit and often Beyond
the goal is to responsibly exit
Investments with impact-aligned buyers
and to consider the effect of the sale
on the sustainability of the impact
achieved as my colleague Ilya strebulov
pointed out in his five takeaways due
diligence is hard work
impact investing which includes the same
due diligence as traditional investing
adds on a layer of impact measurement
this makes it even harder work but
potentially even more rewarding
[Music]
how do I balance ultra running and
teaching and five kids I actually don't
they actually all blend together and you
will often find me wearing flip-flops in
the classroom after a hundred mile race
or you will find me wearing my running
gear during a professional investment
meeting it all just sort of Blends
together and it's one big crazy mess
[Music]
oh